a major update on nevada's vaccine
rollout here's what you need to know
right now starting next week
seniors ages 65 to 69 will be able to
schedule appointments
for the covid19 vaccine if you're
scheduled for a second shot
with the moderna vaccine the rest of
this week be ready for appointment
changes
yeah winter weather across the country
delaying some shipments and appointments
at the chuck minker sports complex have
all been
reserved orco joining erko mana joining
us now from the social
news desk with more on today's changes
denise nevada seniors are rejoicing
tonight 65 to 69 year olds have been
looking at this page of the state's
vaccination playbook
for weeks and they're finally becoming
eligible under the general population
lane
but there are still a lot of questions
about nevada's overall
vaccine allocation we're finally going
to be able to
go outside and not fear
dying 66 year old shirley bryce is
thrilled that nevadans age 65 to 69 can
get the covet 19 vaccine starting next
week
she's been fighting for this moment even
creating an online petition
little late but certainly we're thrilled
with governor sisselok and his team
they listen to our concerns and they're
taking action
but those seniors will only be able to
get the vaccine at pharmacy partners for
right now and the supply is limited
we know it will not be enough to cover
the range of the values of this asia
we continue to ask nevada to be patient
as we await increased allocations from
the federal government
the goal is to expand vaccination events
for those 65 and older by march first
meanwhile the governor is in constant
contact with the white house to get more
vaccines
we're getting the vaccines that we get
into people's act
and although a lot is still uncertain
nevada seniors say one thing is clear
at least we see motion in vaccinating
our age group
now the state's coveted fighter page is
actually a really helpful tool for
seniors and really anyone to look up
vaccine information
and appointment information as well and
we have a link to
this website on our website
eightnewsnow.com
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now